do you have any scars from it I do yeah
take your pants off sorry there's so
unprofessional no but really where is
your scarf my name is Elizabeth South
I'm John I'm a P I here in Los Angeles
today we're gonna play two truths and a
lie
regarding near-death experiences let's
find out which one of these traumatized
Liars is lying
I'm Cheska I was in a surfing accident
when I was nine I'm Tony and while I was
cycling a car plowed through me
I'm Shelby and I was in a deadly car
accident when I was a teenager surfing
accident
you surf much no it was a summer surfing
lessons and how old you you said you
were nine okay how do you know if I can
ask I'm in my late twenties why are you
lying I am in my late I don't know why
you don't have to tell me but you told
me where did this happen this is in the
Philippines okay I grew up there it was
just a summer thing that me and my
cousins did but you don't surf anymore
no not anymore
okay so can you walk us through the
narrative a little bit I mean what what
exactly you were doing and where the
shark came from and that sort of thing
there's no oh yeah did I just want I
just wanted you I all right a surfing
accident okay so take us through the
narrative I try to catch a wave that I
probably shouldn't have you fall off the
board presumably not fell off the board
but the wave just kind of took me under
I spun around a little bit and then I
just smashed my my arm when I'm on a
rock I think I know what's your mom
freaked out when you told her or she my
mom wasn't my mom wasn't there
this sounds bougie but it was it was
mania my nanny and my grandma's driver
this was in the Philippines okay like
people people have nannies yeah right
they have nannies yeah sometimes I just
lived there with you so how deep
underwater were you honestly I don't
think it was that deep I was nine I was
short yeah and I don't think I went that
far and how long were you underwater I
don't think it was that long I think it
was just like I remember like getting a
few go sir but when waves come in
sometimes they come in in succession me
CPR anything No so this shark how big
was it there is no charge you describe
this as a surfing accident what was the
risk to your life I could have hit my
head usually it's like spinal injuries
or like
like injury it was a physical impact the
incident versus like a drowning yeah
alright I think a person I have enough
for the time being I had enough five
minutes ago John I don't know
all right you me yeah you go ahead and
tell me about your experience I was
biking to a friend's house
Calgary uh 20 late 20s I was biking on
the street and I checked over my left
shoulder and so I see a car some
distance behind me and then I just
looked straight forward and then I blink
I feel like and then I'm in a hospital
bed
really what hospital were you in
cedars-sinai was it critical or ICU or
something I did go to ICU the car
smashed into me it's out there my bike
and I got a concussion apparently at the
moment I was fine cops came and
apparently had a conversation with me my
head was split open oh I wasn't wearing
a helmet you weren't wearing a helmet I
normally do I chose not to wear a helmet
because it's a five-minute ride where
was it was it down Hollywood Boulevard
er it was on palms so you live in your
palms Avenue yes what neighborhood is
that also called palms and did your
friend know since you didn't show up I
was on my way to play some Dungeons and
Dragons crucial can I call out specific
lies on this no it's a great game and I
was a half-orc rogue alright if you want
more details so he texted my phone
obvious I didn't answer so then he
texted my girlfriend and my girlfriend
was like oh yeah I guess he didn't know
he's in the hospital what did your
girlfriend date was she freaking out she
sees the bike and she immediately was
like oh geez obviously sir and the cops
are like he's fine actually no we had a
conversation his head is bloody so he's
just getting that stitched up but you
can just pick him up at the hospital he
should be fine and then she comes and
see that I'm unconscious and my pillow
is soaked in blood your pillow is soaked
in blood in the ER yeah so my head was
out I mean it
it was stitched up I guess by the time
she saw it but it was so you know blood
was normally they change that pretty
quick unless you were bleeding like a
lot maybe a lot of time in hospitals
so I don't know especially senior
scientist Oh actually they were staple
they were in stitch and so where did it
click the front so I guess it was from
the left side you guess it was from the
left side I remember seeing the police
printout I kind of believe some of it I
feel like he's mixing incidents maybe
he's just like kind of really bad at
recounting traumatic experiences that's
totally possible Shelby hello yours was
a car accident
right yes so I would tell me about the
shark I was t-boned by a shark no no I
was 16 I was coming home from running
some errands and I was headed down the
road and it was two lanes going this way
and two lanes going the other way and I
was in the left lane I drove through an
intersection when the light started to
turn yellow and there was another car
who was pulling out of like a
supermarket parking lot and he was going
to try to make a left turn and he didn't
see me because there was a car parked
right in the right lane illegally like
were they part kind of long a side road
during certain hours you can park in
certain hours you can yeah exactly
well I know where was this this was in
Phoenix that you're from Phoenix I'm
from Phoenix yeah okay right so his
visibility was like totally odd where
was it's in Phoenix it was in a town
called Goodyear not a lot of people have
heard of it I know I know a bit about it
oh do you
I know a bit about Phoenix Oh God I'm
not really sure what happened but I
guess he like saw the light turned
yellow and was like okay no more cars
coming and he like pulls out in front of
me like gunning it trying to make this
turn so I swerved to miss him and my
front end Clips his front end and then I
proceeded to catch air into oncoming
traffic I rolled like two to three times
and I ended up the car ended up on its
side were you conscious through this
whole experience I was yeah but all I
really remember was like being thrown
around and like this really horrible
crunching sound that I like can't really
describe and who was driving the other
vehicle it was a male it was a guy but I
never really like talk to him or saw him
like I saw him like on the side of the
road he was talking to some authorities
and he had like a cloth on his head but
I didn't speak to him I was like too
overwhelmed to do anything what was he
driving him he was driving a black car I
think it was a Pawnee
but like another sedan or yeah it's just
not like a trucker anyway no yeah we
were both in like smaller sedans and did
anything happen to him you know legally
he was completely excited for it but I
don't really know if he got charged or
anything like that okay I kind of have
my ideas unfortunately I believe her
feel like hers is really solid in the
beginning she seemed a little bit
nervous like when she just did her intro
and everything I thought maybe she might
not him it feels like he combined two
stories to make it real like he was in a
car accident but he changes it to like
bike accident that way he has some of
the details that way they can lie
because they do remember the story it's
too hard to make up story from scratch
so this is my real suspect right now
what are you thinking
I believe Cheska as well I think the
surfing thing happened I mean I think
she's a solid liar but I actually
believe this happened
I think they need I'm not casting a
decision yet but I think a major a major
car accident where you catch air and you
know live live through a deadly car
accident where no one dies that's a
major event obviously it happens all the
time it's not like it never happens then
again the description of the mysterious
crunching noises is a nice little dash
of realism but you're leaning towards
Tony I'm leaning towards Tony
you definitely drilled into him the most
I didn't ask him any questions so I
really said maybe that was my intuition
that gets to him
these two if they are telling lies they
are really liars and they're very
consistent in the way they lie I'm not
fully convinced 200 percent but I think
Tony is a good I think Tony is a prime
suspect Tony you're a liar
[Music]
I was lying you were such a good liar
you are saying she was the one who we're
so sure it was not when people speak
with confidence and they have their
timeline never fabricated or not kind of
down it's really hard to tell what's
what she really got me I'm gonna go cry
now I'll see you guys later
I'm fine I this is the second time this
happen to me
[Music]